like I can carry it up for this we are
live now I think for rent cafe episode
46 it's gonna be a good one this time
we're talking about one punch man season
two and what the hell is happening with
one punch man season two we basically
over a year ago learned that one punch
man season two is in production but
we've never gotten a release date kinda
like we got an announcement recently
that my hero academia is getting a
season three but there was no
announcement but released it's like oh
yeah it's happening it's happening but
that's all we know and however with one
punch man season two just last week we
learned that they're switching the
studio that's making it from madhouse to
a j.c.staff they're switching the
director a whole bunch of other key
staff members so this really is not
usual it's very concerning in terms of
is this season even going to happen so
as big one punch man fans we're gonna be
discussing this today and joining me
today I have a brand new guest first
time on Wren cafe now agarra what's up
hello however how is everyone good
welcome
how do you here I we met on the discord
an amount for discord server and then on
boo told me you're a youtuber we got to
get her on Ranke face so now you're here
yes yes I'm here I'm the very I'm very
small I'm very happy you guys have me
thank you pleasure to have you know
agarra and of course her channel link is
in the description also joining us today
we have soul maka and anime recon and we
were supposed to have ja talks too much
in here as well however he's having
trouble getting in for some reason his
computer is going Spacey on him so if he
can't get in unfortunately that sucks
but he was supposed to join us too but
his channel link is in the description
as well and today I think for the first
time officially we have soul macas
channel guys soul maka finally what made
a video on his channel and that link is
in the description as well you guys can
check it out for the first
I'm pretty pretty psyched soul to have
you on the YouTube train how does it
feel Tyron no no it's yeah no I just
need to you know work out my free time
so I can dedicate more time to making
videos and you know building up my
content yeah yeah so now you see what
I've been dealing with my friend now you
see when people are like oh man was that
next video
oh when's this video coming when's that
video coming when someone's like hey
Anna Mac why don't you re watch all
Kannada and make that video about the
Kannada ending now you see how hard that
is right yeah yeah yeah plus he has the
four kids in the mix yes well I have a
younger brother so I have one thing to
tell you work your ass off that's what
you need to do I'm already doing that
with my job do that on YouTube as well
it's hard when you work a full-time job
I can I can vouch for that when you work
a full-time job and you try to do you
type like YouTube full-time it's a
living nightmare
yeah because to do YouTube seriously you
have to take it as a full-time job like
you have to consider a full-time job if
you want to be doing it seriously and so
is you working two full-time jobs it's
almost impossible to do it and also a
normal life like a normal person right
Oh impossible I have I have one human
like real-life friend but most of my
friends are online now as well so this
is it these are the people these are the
ones that are set forth for life so love
them I love how Josh stuffed me in the
Chad's like hey Anna Mac where's that
command video I don't think I think he's
busy today I think he has some
work-related stuff there's a guy there's
a guy in a cha kept tabs 2:15 he's
asking about seven deadly sins season
two and so far that is lined up for
January 28th
yes so long with overload as well
Overlord is January 2018 and so did
Netflix original series basically if
that means nothing saying it's an
Netflix original series all that means
is that Netflix is gonna have
distribution rights to it when it comes
here but it's not gonna be released on
Netflix first it's gonna be released in
Japan first you know Netflix has nothing
to do really with the production so yeah
it's it's a weird misleading thing that
they say it's a Netflix original oh no
that's what I want yeah I mean it's like
the others that are coming out the
Godzilla back I'm excited for that it's
most likely gonna be in the cinemas
though the Godzilla anime yeah yeah
definitely Yemen will hook up from watch
it will go with it yeah yeah and by the
way recon in Seoul since they're both in
England they recently met in real life
guys yes it was amazing because he never
bought a body pillow I uh I was when I
talked is me yeah yeah what I talked
with me is just being a normal guy
outside from what I am on YouTube like a
huge SEO fan but in real life I'm
completely different I'm just a generic
average guy just me very trying to yeah
my buddy's a big Sao fan so I'm not yes
thank you like obsessed everytime
usually when we have a new guest and
they were they discovered that recon is
a non-ironic Sao fan they have like a
moment of like what the [ __ ] like misty
misty was like is this guy like joking
like it's this is he being sarcastic and
we're like no Mandy's for reals like oh
my god see that's the reason why there's
different industries that are thriving
like harem or like weird
you know just the weird stuff because or
that people dislike because there are
shanwa of people that really do enjoy
that you know so you can't hate on it
because it's doing well yeah and that's
that's your boy recon he's the Karim
King he called I like I like how she
said good stuff I dig it I like the
weird stuff you know I watch that's I
mean I don't watch Sao but I mean I
watch you know all the like harems that
people didn't like or you know that you
know I watch them all I think they're
good it depends it depends like for
example High School DxD Recon loves that
I'm not a fan I watched a few episodes I
was like man coming fast forward to the
non plot parts like I've actually
watched one episode of that I've haven't
watched the whole series only one
episode I'm like this is too much it's
just too much TV for me man it's just
way too much tea I was like this is way
too much fanservice for me it's like
it's like bible black but like yeah like
anywho we have Jojo talks too much in
the chat poor guy he was like I said he
was trying to get any cuz he was having
technical problems he said his computer
took a Saitama punch to the face and so
unfortunately with us in the stream but
yeah so in terms of this whole one punch
man season 2 thing I don't know I want
to get your guys thoughts on this cuz I
myself I talked about this in a little
news video we did it's like I'm quite a
bit concerned because like I said we got
the confirmation over a year ago oh yeah
it's gonna happen guys and now we're not
getting any release dates I was thinking
you know months ago we would get a
release date like we did for someone at
least since they're like okay it's
coming in January overlord season 2 even
attack on Titan which we waited for
years ended up getting season 3
announcement for spring of 2018
thankfully hopefully my hero academia
announcement is going to come soon for
season 3 as well but yeah like what do
you guys think about this one punch man
see - by the way so I don't know if
you're following the manga I'm not cut
off to the manga but you know does that
give you any clue about what's going on
well yeah I mean I'm reading the manga
and I'm guessing that the next season
will be covering the hero killer who is
a student of someone and he's hunting
down heroes that's probably the main
villain but in terms of like its
production and what's going on
I did find like the people who are in
charge now when they it was a troll post
I sweat down because they said like oh
they were given like a preview like of
art and you know just to show you the
you know you can have faith in their art
style I and they drew saitama's face but
they drew Satan's face you know in his
simplistic form ya know that simple just
a circle to circular eyes and a smile
that's it that's what they did I was
like what days there's such a troll
that's such a flow yeah I mean cuz that
shows no like real artistry yeah I mean
anyone could do that
my son could do that what what is
happening you guys think it's actually
going to happen or do you think there's
some issues with like perhaps as they
say creative differences which often
means you know maybe the manga author
one is in conflict with the anime staff
or something crazy like that and then
it's just being consistently dragged
through the mud I don't know what do you
guys think um personally I I think this
all just makes perfect sense it was a
really really high demand when madhouse
did it and not only that they did a lot
of outsourcing as well and they did have
a lot of passion when they put into the
project as well so I feel like the other
studio is just you know what I mean
that's that's a big freaking don't like
to carry off and baton to try to toss
off so I just feel like I feel like it's
going to come but it's probably going to
be something like 2019 or you know
20 yeah kind of like attack on Titan
season 2 we might get a long long wait
which sucks because yeah I was thinking
because we had the announcement like
over a year ago that season 2 would be
Greenland I was thinking you must be
almost done by now like maybe we'll get
a spring 2018 announcement for the
release date but if they're switching
Studios now then I'm thinking it hasn't
even been started yes who knows when
we're gonna actually get it which sucks
so hard and that's such a big like yeah
think about how big one punch man was it
even got big here in America for people
that didn't like anime loved it you know
what I mean so like it got so big and
that's such a big weight load to carry I
can definitely see why this is taken
forever
yeah and that's the thing it did get
popular even among non anime fans which
only a few animes do like I think I
would say attack on Titan did and you
know like you know the Dragon Ball
franchise but not a lot of anime get to
that point
Josh says he thinks j.c.staff is going
to do a good job that we shouldn't be on
edge my problem is not necessarily with
the studio it's who knows how long this
is gonna take now come on my problem is
with why are they getting to the point
where they're switching Studios in the
first place like that cannot be a good
sign whatsoever I mean you can get a
little bit quickie that they are
switching directors I would think yeah
there cuz they are switching directors
as well and a bunch of other key staff
members so I don't know why Cass is
still listening
I don't know I'm concerned myself
because things might not be the same as
it was in the first season maybe
story-wise Animation wise and all this
stuff cuz I mean I've watched quite
quite a few anime j.c.staff has done
some were good some we're bad so I'm not
really too keen they're gonna know how
to do one punch man perfectly like that
how's this oh yeah I'm a little bit
scared I'm gonna post some links in the
chat because I think I just found some
other images of what he's gonna look
like now so I'll post in here for us to
now post them in like the
the actual channel chat for everyone
else to see so we can comment on them
yeah and that's always it's always
really screwed up when you have an
iconic anime like one punch man like now
I gotta said it got big world and now
you're gonna be changing you know
Studios like that you're gonna try to
make it similar but there's gonna be
some differences and you know hardcore
fans are gonna nitpick on any difference
and be like why would they change this
why would they change that so yeah like
I feel like they would not have changed
studios and directors if there wasn't
some big underlying issue perhaps
rivalry or like a disagreement between
the creator of the manga and the
webcomic and the anime staff or
something like that which sucks because
one punch man is popular it's definitely
gonna be profitable so it sucks when you
have you have enough material to go on
from the manga you have you know it's
gonna be profitable and yet you're still
having problems because of like personal
issues and stuff like that yeah that's
also a major key issue as well I mean
the only thing that I think in a
scenario like this I always say is hope
for the best
expect the worst most definitely yeah
yeah I don't know but we have few people
I saw anime dude and NeoGeo Saint
Congrats on 60 thousand subscribers
thank you so much that is insane we've
reached 60,000 like last night or
something and we started off this year I
think in January we hit three thousand
so after the new year so it's just crazy
to be at 60,000 doesn't even feel real
but you know we'll just keep pushing man
we'll keep pushing until everyone's like
rolling these guys are pushing oh that's
freaking amazing that is a good
accomplishment keep going and of course
rant cafe is a big part of the channel
and just having fun with fellow
youtubers and everybody in the chat it's
always a great time thanks Lucario
uh yeah recon your thoughts on one punch
man I know I'm gonna guess you're on
with the manga no I have not read
manga excellent yes so tell me why you
like the book season 1 and what you hope
to get in season 2 and do you think
season 2 is even gonna happen I think
it's gonna happen yeah if j.c.staff can
get it on time I mean I know we don't
have a release date yet but uh who knows
they're gonna maybe they're gonna nail
it maybe they won't nail it maybe it's
gonna be a failure maybe it's not gonna
be a failure but what I like about
season one that madhouse has done is the
entire premise of the show the animation
the characters I mean everything was
just so on point everything was perfect
I loved it so much the fact that it's
gonna get a season two and we've heard
that j.c.staff is gonna be doing it the
director changed all the staff has
changed who knows what's gonna happen so
yeah it's a big mystery yeah it's huge
unexpected news that j.c.staff is gonna
do it yeah I think they're wrong why are
they giving up a huge popular mainstream
show to j.c.staff
I mean Matt how it should be doing it
why would they carry it over - j.c.staff
that's a little mistake that's a I'm
working on overlord season - and that's
a really extreme project that they're
taking on right now and they need all of
the staff for that yes one punch man is
more important than Overlord it's what I
think mostly I would say it's more
popular for sure you stop it yeah that's
what I'm thinking is it may be you know
like a personal problem between the
staff or between you know the creator
and the anime staff because otherwise it
doesn't make sense like for a studio to
not want to make a profitable anime it's
already been greenlit people are waiting
for it right you have the staff in place
you already didn't like one season it's
not brand new so it's like it does seem
weird for that to be happening and
that's why I'm leaning towards maybe
there's some kind of personal
disagreements which sucks because people
shouldn't let that kind of stuff get in
the way of the business and producing
great entertaining content but I do hope
that you know the JC stuff can take hit
the ground running and obviously they do
have the
got to go by so they're not gonna just
completely change up you know the
storyline or screw up the storyline or
something like that because they have
material that they go by so that's a
good thing
personally I love the first season I
thought it was hilarious I love the
humor Moomin Ryder guys Neiman Ryder yes
so that's to me to me like I know a lot
of people including very respectable
reviewers whose opinions I respect they
said that the one punch man kind of
concept got old to them fast like it's
like the same joke all over over and
over again but to me it was still funny
I found it an interesting funny show
throughout so I was a fan throughout
personally so what about you oh yeah we
like season 1 and what do you think
about season 2 yeah no yeah season 1 was
um it was great season 1 was great it
did get me into the manga and yeah I
think yeah I think it's a great show the
the whole like one punch joke thing I
think it is really good I would say for
those who think I don't know just like
focusing on that one joke gets boring
then you'll be glad to know later on in
the manga he actually starts thinking
seriously about his life and what he's
doing with himself but yeah season 2 I'm
definitely looking forward to it I am
dying to see some fights especially
what's his name watchdog watchdog versus
the villain there's gonna be involved
that is that is the fight I want to see
because that watchdog guy is like like
Opie but you'd never think it cuz the
way he looks you know cuz he's in that
dog seat and he's like you know null and
void expressionless
but he's so Opie I swear to god he's
crazy
as for j.c.staff
they have done some good stuff you know
for those who like shokugeki no souma
that's JC stuff yeah I mean those you
like toreador
that's Jason stuff yeah I mean familiar
of 0jz stuff you know so I mean they
can't do good you know they can't do
good
Gordon time Shakugan no Shana yeah I
mean was it the magical index cumin
prison school you know they can't do
good so I do have faith in them as a
studio I think they could do well but I
don't know I don't know because I'm not
too sure about all the other stuff
they've got like ongoing at the moment
and how that would affect the production
like for example with toy animation one
piece has been pretty okay consistent
pretty much but once they started doing
Dragon Ball super the artwork on both
series started to suffer so you know
something like that could happen you
know they're already doing shokugeki no
souma i'm not sure what else they're
already doing but then once they start
doing like if they're doing like one
punch one season two like concurrently
with other series it might like stretch
them a bit fin and then you know it
might suffer some animation dips and
then you know we'll be comparing it then
to the whole madhouse version and we'll
be like the madhouse looked awesome why
does this look so shoddy j.c.staff you
suck yeah I mean but yeah that's a
classic anime a fan thing to be like you
look at the smallest difference in your
look at this they ruined one punch man
is one of their favorite and newer anime
and manga and I have to agree when I
think about you know let's say the last
five years one punch man is definitely
there and one of the top anime that I
like other ones include killa kill and
like attack on Titan and diet type of
stuff but absolutely like it's one of
the ones that I think of right away when
you think about like newer anime post
2010 that are still
badass and kind of good because the
enemy man just posted actually on
Twitter
I saw it long ago saying that is it just
me or are a lot of newer animators crap
like he can't think of that many new
anime that were good this year and I
have to agree like there's a lot of
recon type stuff there's a lot of really
copying you told me about black clover
right I did watch the first episode okay
I know I was pretty disappointed yeah I
was a bit disappointed I was as well
I want everyone I want that when we knew
it I just I just [ __ ] new studio
parents parents however you pronounce
their name we're gonna [ __ ] it up I just
knew it I knew they were gonna [ __ ] it
up
no but it's not I wouldn't say it's them
who messed it up anyway cuz I mean it's
just the story itself is bad just added
to it that just like you know that was
the nail in the coffin yeah that was
terrible that was his voice acting was
just so [ __ ] annoying I couldn't
handle it was like JC stuff might use
something like that they might choose
someone for Saitama that you know if
they can't get the original think as
well is it still well they're still
gonna keep the same yeah same yeah they
still gotta sing kiss oh and that's
alright now that's alright then yeah
yeah that's what I was freaked out about
- I make sure it's the same cast like I
said before like I think madhouse they
could have had a disagreement for sure
but I really think this was an
outsourcing issue because it was at
first you know big demand as well and
they put a lot of passion and do it and
there was a lot out sourcing I think it
was failed outsourcing for the people
that they originally had on the first
project
well did madhouse also do the to recap
movies for over
I think maybe maybe that's what it was
maybe doing those two doing another
second season and whatever else they had
there might have been stretching
themselves Finn and you know like you
know what we can't handle this the way
it should
we're gonna have to pass it on to
someone exactly maybe maybe that's what
I think that's just my prediction don't
take that into fact because there's a
lot we don't know about the enemy in
this tree and that's kind of what sucks
because you know with Western shows like
Game of Thrones for example or any shows
you will often know like a year ahead of
time you know season the next season is
coming it's coming at this time and
you're a call cool and you know it's
coming and you're prepared with anime I
think was attack on Titan season two we
learned like two months before it came
out oh by the way guys the target on
season 2 is coming out in April yep yep
it was like after four years just like
boom April is like yeah so I think anime
in this tree is very like in terms of
communication there is not a lot of it
and there's a lot of you know just
sudden decisions and things happening
not working out that you know we're not
necessarily used to when you look at
western productions and Hollywood
production is stuck as how the movies
can be you know being made for two years
and you know when they're supposed to
come out and all that stuff it's all on
Wikipedia it's all there so I think it's
it's something we have to get used to
with the anime industry it doesn't work
on Micah Clark it's very which is weird
because the Japanese are set to be very
efficient and you know pun intended
yeah we had some people in here in the
chat saying that their favorite new
anime is content cop and man idubbbz is
crazy man
I'm so definitely one conscious these
youtubers see just one punches then it's
not like when I was it's like it says
Jake Paul and I'm like oh [ __ ]
everyone's expecting this it's like well
actually this isn't on Jay Paul at all
this is on rice gum it's like what do
bamboozled he's not
and then they PewDiePie's in there h3h3
Oh everybody it was it was it was like a
youtuber mind of like the coolest
maniacs YouTube occult
yeah super super cool for sure oh man
yeah I knew about all that crazy should
have a rice come before but caster for
life says his favorite new anime is neo
yoki oh yes oh no nominee but I just
made a video and published it today
about why I think it was a brilliant
animated series from American animated
series and comedy so yes guys I haven't
yet so is it upon oh you're being
serious please say he's being serious
I'm happy because no one will step out
and say hey you know what this was
actually a really good marketing
strategy because even if you do think
it's frickin stupid you still got
something a lot of you you are still
going to talk about it
you are still going to talk about like I
had people pissed off in my discord
about it today talking about it like why
would they do something like this and
like you're talking about it there they
worked didn't it all of you are talking
about it
yeah like the total groan is such a
brilliant mean and you know they knew it
was gonna be a week yeah they knew it
was gonna be I mean wasn't like one of
those they were trying to you know they
were trying to actually be poetic with
it or something and then it became a
mean because it was so stupid it's like
they knew that this was going to be a
mean and and a lot of the stuff as I
mentioned in my video it's that
absurdist surreal sort of comedy and
that's what they're going for they're
not trying to get taken seriously just
like hey Joe is not trying to be taken
as a serious sports anime it's like what
much man is not trying to be taken as a
sort of gritty dark knight type show or
like a like a superhero show there for
what they know what they are the show
knows what it is it it doesn't take
itself too seriously and that's why it
works and I think neo yoki oh absolutely
works in that sense no my my point would
be against it like as a product because
yeah as like a piece of art getting
whether it's neck
or positive like feedback works in it
because it Garner's attention but as a
product is something that they want to
sell negative doesn't help they're not
help sell it yeah I totally have
something to say to that
okay do you remember like a while back
Funimation did a really terrible English
dub and they used all of their best
English voice actors it was either for
an anime called like ghost hunt or ghost
stories or something like that and the
reason why they did that was because
they knew that the storyline itself in
Japanese was a very dull storyline and
they wanted to it was some kind of
marketing poll that they did they
purposely dubbed it terribly but that
winded up being one of the most
hilarious best marketing polls that
they've ever did and I think that was
like I honestly kind of feel like that
was Netflix a small attempt to do that
no no I mean it was good to get
attention but how well did it sell we're
talking about no no no no no no they
don't mean it sold in the bargain bin so
you're wrong for the for the very reason
that the business model the Netflix does
is streaming and so the people they're
gonna watch Netflix they already have
Netflix memberships so it's not about
you buying going out and buying the
product okay how many times especially
an anime community when someone gives
something a bad rep do people just hate
on it without even trying to watch it
yeah well that's why I brought on on the
revolutionary that drop the video
praising it and now pedantic romantic is
one day going to make a video called how
anime uproar saved Neo Tokyo I I didn't
get what you were like they're coming
from from that the people that do just
they'll jump in and they will
automatically hate it and just go with
other people because they dislike it as
well yeah I know
and they won't watch it so it won't get
any extra revenue that is just gonna be
seen as oh it's truck that's it
ghost hunt oh no I didn't want you I
heard stories
have you watched just because came out
today I've been at work all day
I've just got home watch it I was so
impressed by the first episode my food
and my Buffy's waiting for me it's like
it's going into proper romance this
series yes okay well yeah I mean is one
that I want to check out that one and if
you don't say one and if you don't say
what hasn't let me down anyways the
point of me ochio is that they made an
homage to anime with blatant references
to anime and all that type of stuff but
it is not an anime it's a Western
cartoon and like I said it reminds me of
you know Adult Swim cartoons like Harvey
Birdman attorney at law that type of
stuff not you know it's not supposed to
be an animate obviously draws a lot from
anime it pays tribute to anime but it's
it's own thing if we shouldn't judge it
based anime and since we are talking one
punch man I think one thing about one
punch man is that they also knew they
were gonna be making a meme when they
made the webcomic the manga and then the
show because they knew that this was it
was drawing on a lot of other stuff so
like superhero stuff you know Dragonball
Z type anime with a lot of fighting in
action but you know it we know all the
talk of Opie characters about Goku being
Opie and all that stuff they said why
not take that to the extreme let's
create a character that is obviously a
mean because he can defeat anyone with
one punch and let's just make it a
comedy game and we know it's a comedy
anime we know it's not yeah make it like
a masterpiece of action and one punch
one is different it's like everyone like
pretty much who gay like either these
things though I was seeing funny
right oh they'll see is like super Opie
guy and it's great yeah I mean there are
few there are few to get tired of it
like oh yes just one joke over and over
again that is like the most minimal
complaint you ever hear sure yeah I mean
that's the most minimal but where's neo
yoky oh it's over it's mama it's yeah I
love it or you hate it and that's it
but that's why you're saying we
shouldn't be at all like as an anime
community where you know like step back
completely and analyze this as a Western
cartoon something is like an Adult Swim
nature that we are all because they're
using anime memes and stuff like that
the anime community feels like this is
something that needs to be judged critic
and attacked somebody jokes though like
a lot of won't get anyway cause like
they like referencing like certain
fashions and products and things like
that like when he sees the guy at the
grave and he starts talking about like
what product would have been better you
know as a perfume to use because of how
it's sold and that it yeah other some
people just gonna see that anything what
is this about why why is he mumbling
about some perfume that was supposed to
be funny
yummy people it shows his upbringing how
vain he is as a person and how he
doesn't understand what really matters
in life because of that so he the bad
one all right forget that though yeah I
mean not everyone is gonna find that
funny what they sold just because some
people are close-minded and they don't
want to get it that doesn't make it a
bad show no no no no I don't mean their
clothes it's just that sense of humor if
they're like no because I don't get the
joke or this has to be bad because I
want a protagonist that I can relate to
not a guy that's essentially an antihero
because he's a product of his ridiculous
society and as a commentary on that
society then yeah if you only want a
Naruto and that's the only kind of anime
you why he could then yeah that's called
mine well I I actually agree with with
where both of you guys are covered
because he's like
your code like huh guess I kind of agree
with the close - state mail I mean
you're coming from also you get the
westernized jokes and stuff like that
cuz you know we're we're right next door
you know what I mean like Canada they've
everyone there they get the westernized
jokes we read you have somebody there
overseas in the whole entire world
they're going to look at this and be
like what the hell is this not only that
we do get people that are mostly coming
from the anime community judging this so
they're not going to have that open
state of westernized culture cartoon ISM
in their mind when they're trying to
judge this this is all based off their
own anime knowledge yeah and like the
other thing is I don't know I'm not a
huge fan of a lot of these like Adult
Swim pipe shows but like there's huge
fans of like Adventure Time cartoons
like you know Ren & Stimpy Rick and
Maureen's Bob yeah and if you look at
the animation for these cartoons it's
like nowhere near good like the
animations is almost deliberately bad
and yet people still love it and that's
why when people are saying you know neo
yoki animation is bad yeah it does look
amateurish but for these types of
cartoons that's not a deal-breaker
because a lot of them are even worse and
people don't remember like cow and
chicken and [ __ ] like these were so
called classics even though the
animation was terrible and like what
Venture Bros like I said Adventure Time
Harvey Birdman attorney at law I thought
was hilarious it's an older show but
it's just is it already hasn't really
gotten really for example they one
episode where you know Harvey Birdman is
defending Fred Flintstone and Friends
Flintstone is a mafia Godfather like
that was good yeah like and again if
you're like me this makes no sense
Fred Flintstone is from the you know
ancient era and Harvey Birdman is from
the modern times what is this show what
is this show like if you're taking and
same thing with one punch man if you're
taking it as well no human can just run
10 kilometers a day and do push-ups and
sit-ups and be this strong this makes no
sense this makes no sense guys
that's true yeah well no it's la casa is
down it comes down to knowledge what the
person hasn't like if I'm not aware of
certain products in fashion him making a
reference of it means nothing to me
because I don't understand the product
so I'm not gonna get any kind of humor
there is supposed to be like connected
to that product because I have no
knowledge of the product yeah yeah and
that's in close-minded I'm whatever it's
just I that's not in my life yeah I mean
I'm not involved with that fashion side
so I'm not gonna get it I'm not gonna
connect with it it's just impossible
because you don't have to get it so you
can only do me if you don't get the joke
how you gonna laugh at the joke but
that's not the joke the joke is what a
pretentious douchebag the main character
is for him to be so into fashion in the
first place that's all you have to get
is that they're ridiculously into
fashion to the point that it's just like
what are you doing man yeah the
character of Helena sent Tesoro calls
them out like straight up says like who
cares what you're wearing this is all
pointless spectacle stuff like that
and Kaz the main guy gets all depressed
and lonely and [ __ ] because of stupid
stuff like fashion and his suit being
midnight blue and then midnight blue
because the next thing and then he's
like oh [ __ ] like that's the whole point
it makes no sense it's absurd the
concept of fashion is absurd modern
society is absurd and yo-yo is just
exposing it to a little little bit over
exaggerated level but it's supposed to
be shining a mirror on our own society
how absurd you can be regarded fashion
yes so the thing is you're not supposed
to be relating to Cass Khan and it's not
just fashion it's vanity in general
you're not supposed to be relating to
you're supposed be like this guy's
[ __ ]
but he's [ __ ] because of the society
so it's not like a classic protagonist
that I want to be I want to be him it's
like he's almost like an antihero
not that he's evil or anything he's just
he's like he's just completely vain in
like a recon say
something give me her piggy you guys
seem to know what you're doing so you
know I'm starting to feel the vibe of an
American versus Souls I'm like okay I'm
back and all in terms of one punch man
Rico because I know your fan I mean
you're talking about [ __ ] jokes and
[ __ ] like that so I know but most jokes
funny with one punch man there's he's
also not a relatable character in the
sense that he sold pee right he's the
main character but he's so old Pete
anonymous can relate to him so what do
you think makes him still an interesting
character then because he's bold and we
will all be bored one day no no but he's
relatable in the sense of we understand
that type of character we've grown up
with it we know it you know how it works
yeah so we can connect with it yeah
because we're all used to it we all
understand how that character works but
then you know yo Keo is something alien
well you only certain people are gonna
get ya I mean but not everyone's gonna
get it because that's not the norm for
everyone you know some people don't care
about like name brands and labels yeah I
mean so those people are not gonna care
that this guy's acting like that they're
not gonna find it humorous they're just
gonna think always idiot and that's it
they're just gonna get from a negative
you know place no no yeah but it's gonna
be a negative feeling with it it's not
oh he's easy haha look at him it's gonna
be all these idiot this is dumb oh this
is stupid
what the hell's going on why are they
doing this oh forget this that's it you
both have really really really good
points you both have really good points
because the aspect there you know there
are people that should just look at it
and the same you know after hire like
this is its own show for what it is it's
not an anime you know but you do got
people all over
the world that has Netflix you know what
I mean in different cultures and
different regions with anime they fit it
in with all their jokes to where anybody
can adapt from it doesn't matter what
culture where you're from when we
westernized something we put jokes about
Kanye you know we talked about Louis
Vuitton and Gucci and certain sprays
like that like we talk about stuff
that's so westernized that like people
from UK Japan they're like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about so I understand
both sides yeah and the thing with the
thing with I think these types of anime
it's interesting because Netflix is
interesting like Netflix there's not a
lot of stupid [ __ ] as we know they did
the whole labeling seven deadly sins
season two an OVA or TV special as
season two and there was all this
confusion about it they did the the
freakin Death Note movie like you guys
know that I'm not saying I like new
ochio just to be like a contrary and
nobody liked it so I'm like I liked it
because I hate it a definite movie and
most people hate it and I was like yeah
it sucked
it sucked as a movie it sucked as its
own it sucked as an adaptation what
Netflix also does have one punch man for
example one of the anime they have they
have some other ones like Knights of
Cydonia and things like that they they
called them original releases meaning I
guess that they're the distributors for
the West but yeah they so Netflix isn't
interesting in the anime community
because while they have some good anime
and might be a positive influence in
stomach to some extent they're also like
very iffy and have done some shady
things in the past so yeah it's a
definitely weird platform to be holding
anime on for sure especially when you
know pretty sure headquarters are
[ __ ] located in America so yeah weird
kind of setup that they have definitely
and they also have that whole thing guys
that you know where they release
everything all at once meaning that
they're not doing weekly releases which
is not at all how anime works right like
anime comes on a weekly basis and
everyone wants to watch it as soon as
possible so when they like what they did
with a little bit chucking them
or academia they took they released it
all like after a while anyone that was
coming on in Japan weekly and people
were complaining it's like why am I
paying for Netflix membership as an
anime fan if you're the only ones with
the right to distribute this show and
you're not you're wait until it ends
like six months after it starts is when
I can actually watch it like yeah it's a
platform for sure I think they do it
just for like you know in cases like the
live actions that may come out or in
case you know the neo one that came out
you know what I mean like there's you
know what I mean
I think they expected something and it
wasn't what you expected yeah I realized
that Netflix they like the whole binge
watching aspect but you know people who
want a binge watch can wait they have
that option well people who want to
watch as soon as it comes out should
also have the option of just watching it
as soon as it comes out right most
definitely Netflix does that sometimes
it's certain like TV shows like some of
the shows that my missus used to watch
they used to do it with like was it
Pretty Little Liars like every week a
new episode so I mean they can't do it
when they have the license or rights to
I guess but yeah they've never done it
with anime I've never seen yeah I don't
watch Pretty Little Liars for obvious
reasons like but I did watch the 100 and
they did that they release them weekly
my office I fly show yeah I think the
best thing that you're gonna get from
Netflix is hoping any like that like
them having your HD nice quality movies
and when they come out with a live
actions and hoping that they're not bad
[Music]
cuz they're gonna get more live action
so yeah they're gonna have actions not
bad I don't see those two words OCC this
is the whole thing like the Death Note
Luffy that he mentioned before I've had
a lot of people that aren't anime fans
at all they hate anime and you know they
don't say it's good they say it's an
okay movie but it had a really bad
ending you know what I mean
so it's like once in a while I mean how
do you guys
ah ghost in the shell' live-action film
oh no that's alright I still haven't
seen it to be honest
actual movie as a ghost in the shell'
movie it wasn't good
exactly spider-man homecoming is a good
action movie why is it terrible
spider-man movie
exactly exactly so it's like yeah I'll
take the good with the bad you know what
I mean you know that they're not gonna
match up to it but in hopes that maybe
it's a good movie yeah without a
patient's you really have to not expect
much but my problem with like the
Netflix mood with the death no movie is
that it essentially did not even live up
to the hype of a movie on its own even
if you didn't know anything about death
thought you were stuff like why would
this dude reveal this power after he
just used it to kill someone to a random
chick like are you kidding me
like what is that that was not a good
show guys there were so many wrongs
there were so many wrongs that was not
comparable at all with the anime I
literally was like face palming my
forehead was so [ __ ] right at the end
of the movie yeah I know and it's like
even if like obviously the guy can't
even compare to my leg like Turner is a
joke but even if you just take him for
what he is like a regular dude it's like
what are you doing man like you're what
you're doing like they make him off as
he's supposed to be smart he does all
the stupid [ __ ] in the film and then at
the end he does a like a no game no life
genius play that no one anticipated but
then again even throughout the movie
like he was like this
Oh whiney like light wasn't like that
like light knew what he was doing he
wasn't in me personally how I untick the
whole series that he wasn't really in
love with the chick he was just using
her because you know her his freakin
plan and it's they just it all
the only one that was good as William
Dafoe thank God your newest actor and
you did Rio cute off' alia but the whole
film no yeah if anything rheic could
have had a bigger role then but he
didn't really so yeah I don't know yeah
by the way Gilgamesh says Netflix shares
the love of fate to all
it's true I did watch fate/zero and
amendment blade works on Netflix so
again we have a love and hate
relationship with Netflix because they
bring us some quality anime in really
good quality visuals and everything like
that
and then on the other hand they do some
really stupid stuff so yeah I don't know
Netflix bro it's kind of cool though
because it constantly gives you
something to wonder what they're gonna
do next you know it's fun to critique
them yeah like but I'm really what I
thought was really sick on me was the
seven deadly sins season two thing they
did because they there was a four
episode TV special so kind of like an
OVA but it actually if actually aired on
TV and in Japan called signs of a holy
war and they build it on Netflix as
season two and I was because we're we do
news on this channel so I was looking at
before it even came out I was like
there's no evidence in Japan that season
two came up so are they saying that is
gonna come out on Netflix before it
comes out in Japan and people were
thinking that's what they were saying
however when it came out we realized it
was not at all a full season two and
people were so confused some people like
they wanted to renew their membership
for that month for example because they
wanted to see someone at least in season
two so in that sense I thought it was
very shady business practice to do that
because I'm sure they're not stupid they
know I'm anime season it's not four
episodes anyone should know that I mean
everyone basic knowledge of enemy should
know that a season is longer than four
episodes but I don't know somewhere I
don't know oh no too ignorant to that
fact I guess they're just taking it by
you know what it was titled us and
saying that that's the truth and the guy
who made the decision to call it season
two should have known better
that's yeah yeah the anime dude i love i
love how he trolls me cuz he knows this
pisses me off cuz like i made videos
about this before and then i still on
those videos which were published months
ago saying this is not a real season 2
that's on netflix
is just a TV special I still get people
saying bro seven deadly sins season two
is on Netflix I'm watching it right now
you idiot
yeah that's YouTube for you guys
and so the anime dudes like he's like
suddenly since season two is already on
Netflix Lohan iMac yeah the true god of
anime says he's comparing Netflix to
four kids
yes four kids that's another another
painful chat during the activate
community
jelly-filled doughnuts and such I mean
little kids I mean this is the whole
thing too is like when four kids they
were airing freaking kids anime so like
I don't understand the whole processing
of like re-editing the anime like I
don't understand that I know what like
it's okay they did like Digimon and [ __ ]
but then why are you doing like one
piece where there's death all over the
place and then doing out like a
censorship thing it said what are you
gonna do attack on Titan and be like yo
geo was the worst he's in a banana he is
now person is a banana
he's just like the skin flap instead the
legs and stuff you know that's it's like
our Sanji's cigarette changed in it way
too much if you're giving one don't say
don't give me too much one piece boilers
cuz I just started watching that
actually and I'm on like episode I'm
just saying like the visual changes like
the censorship the focus change oh my
god well can a cigarette he would always
have a lollipop in his hand yeah I'm
saying like instead of Titans eatin
people they're changing into bananas and
where the limbs would be flapping it'd
be like the skin of the banana you know
and instead yeah like that
crazy which is crazy aqus the four kids
version is how a lot of people were
introduced to one piece and then they
felt like this is so immature it's
stupid like we have a whole video on the
channel which talks about the top the
10th 10 changes that four kids made to
one piece and it's already like
approached 150,000 views it was doing
really well because it's such a sore
topic and yeah there's so many it's
changing guns into water guns for
example yeah it's just the you do the
cards one that's the one that shocked me
it was the changing of the cards on
yu-gi-oh
that was just so great because like my
whole entire perception was the show was
kind of childish and extremely stupid
and I was mad because it totally like
killed Pokemon around the time in my
neighborhood and I was the kid that was
like f you guys I'm still playing
Pokemon but the cards were just like the
nudity on them I was just so shocked
about the nudity on the cards yeah yeah
and that's and that's basically what
they did with everything they just like
dumbed it down and like you yo is not
even that severe when you look at any
other anime but like they still like
mean it's so childish
one piece is definitely an amazing treat
because like I was really into DBZ and I
fell off after the Buu saga because I
got really upset at like you know just
how it was changing and GT and so I
never gave one piece a chance and I used
to say what's the point watching
something when you only get 10 minutes
an episode and I used to bash it really
bad but now I'm like obsessed with it
I'm eating my words really bad right now
yeah yeah that's the thing because a lot
of people were exposed to one piece and
something for the first time through
four kids and then they're like man this
is childish like I don't want anything
to do with this so yeah it's definitely
a weird thing where if you were exposed
to it you you've got a completely
different idea of what it really is
through four kids then you know the
truth behind it but yeah definitely
anime community is a complex one I saw
matter swordsman in there saying he
apparently wants to see a yogi oh no
Pico oh my god spin-off I thought that
man was dead what is happening
no it's never
never die my name is Jeff is still huge
on this jail oh that's yeah that's still
huge oh and what's the other one that
thingy is anime Cory house yeah yeah
yeah yeah and the Recon no pico is still
there yeah yeah well Rika Rika no people
never done because you refuse to let it
die we need to come up with our own as
an anime community we need to come
together and come up with a list 10 max
of our own anime new fresh means yeah
didn't originate on fortune yeah hey
there yep exactly thank you yes can can
we do it shown in the enemy I know it
started here in rent cafe someone said
it and that sticks shown in the enemy
yes which is the way we made fun of our
block clover because it seems to combine
elements from all these different shown
an enemy just to try to be as good as it
can be so he what he was born without
magic
but then he develops magical powers like
that cool he wants to be the wizard King
instead of the pirate king like like man
this is this black mole thing is just
shown in the enemy I was thinking of
Harry Potter like I was thinking of
Harry Potter means Naruto well even so
Harry Potter oh yeah oh that's even
better it's like Harry Potter fairy tale
that's so perfect yes that's the thing
like it's just a bunch of shonan's
put together and let's see what happens
I haven't seen the first episode dull
I've heard bad things but I have to
watch myself just kind of get my own
first impressions well yeah most Harry
Potter it's too early for us to judge I
just want to say that I always tell
everybody if you're going to judge an
anime series at least get six episodes
in before you walk away from it three
exist another meme that I created no
please no is
recon get the [ __ ] out
[Music]
mutual Mike I couldn't hear the meme can
you say that again you mean well it was
directed to recon it was what we con
said in one of our run cafe sessions he
he said who is Miyazaki so I created the
meme who is Miyazaki we can get the [ __ ]
out is the director of the big Miyazaki
and then our responses you don't know
who Miyazaki is and then you're like oh
was he the guy who had the big cat are
you talking about Totoro Totoro even a
cat in this and our discord made an
image of the cat from the Cat Returns
which is another oh my god
poor guys hey I can only imagine like
god guys like I'm be like okay you don't
know me as like he is America fake you
deserve it and recon is a good sport so
he'll take it yeah he knows no picking
on him we're not being mean so unless it
was nuts not to be mean you know when
we're totally love you when they call
you you know cut and [ __ ] and they
treat you know that's what a bridge gets
really drunk and attacks you physically
this you know that's love right I got
quite no I got quite a few buddies over
there I always tell me that the treat
you like this because we love you you
know that's that
we do it over here I'm like oh really
like that's how you Brits are and he's
like yeah this that's how we are your
[ __ ] tongue okay which is why which
is why I I keep my British people
association limited to like recon and
and soul knock and a few other people I
try to keep that [ __ ] on the down-low
but yes to sum up this whole discussion
in terms of one punch man guys we do not
know anything about a release date
unfortunately yet we are following as
always on this channel we do follow the
news on the official Japanese website
that's usually where this stuff first
comes but right now the last thing we
had was back in September a few weeks
ago or a week and a half ago they
basically said good news everyone new
staff announced for one punch man season
two and it's like good news morning bad
news
they made it seem like oh it's good news
we have new stuff second but then you
want you think oh it's like wait they're
changing staff it's not like oh we have
staff we're working on season two it's a
good thing it's like no they're changing
staff season two is potentially in
trouble but they try to make it you know
they trying to make it seem like a
positive story however yet we don't know
actually when it's gonna come out we
don't know the release date but as soon
as we do know something we'll keep you
posted
however I'm a bit worried hopefully we
are going to see a season 2 in the
respectable future I hope we're not
gonna have another attack on Titan for
your weight hope for the best expect
Thor's yeah I know it's easier to say
that I've been accepting the worst is
like accepting never know why season 2
ever and I'm like but anyway let's wrap
it up guys
no I gotta since you're new you can tell
us first who you are and what you do on
your channel I am now we got it and I do
anime content usually funny skits and do
some comedy anime news kind of like yo
yo ki old best best anime kind of stuff
yes yeah like yeah just it's really
comical
like I just I like to be I like to goof
around
yeah I mean I think we all do we all do
so but that's and yeah you are on our
discord as well correct yep I'm in there
I'm in there I'm silent one but I'm in
there you want to join our discord link
in the description don't forget to leave
a like also on rank buffet if you like
Renko
Hey and thank you now I gotta her link
is into this description we also have
soul maka we have a link in the
description now for him as well since he
launched his channel what's up my man
who are you and what do you do tell
everyone hi I am so Mac she dug my recon
in question but no I'm so maka
you cut me mainly on discord I mainly do
voice chat sessions for hours and hours
on end I am more focused on manga than
anime because there's just more variety
and content in manga and even if you
have like a manga version of the same
story that you have in anime chances are
you've got the complete story in the
manga and an incomplete story in anime
but yeah my channel is gonna show
comparisons between manga and anime but
also try and introduce people to easy
manga to get into so how god would like
typical things like no battle Shonen and
stuff like that maybe some romance drama
and you know things that people would
generally be into yeah that's me also
thank you so and like I said very glad
that you have your channel up and
running now it is I checked it out it is
coming along nicely you have a bunch of
like gaming stuff from before though
yeah yeah just reviewing manga and then
ero gay games that's how we do it happy
Dead or Alive come on man that bounce
bounce no no that's like early Cage oh
man come on man Ubaldo
exactly yeah yeah pop bad and we got
anime recon
tell us who you are what you do my
friend all right what my boys it's your
boy recon here and I do them animate top
tens and yeah awesome awesome very nice
short and sweet I don't know my own time
my own discord server is why I made it
yeah I know the link is not in
description because I only on my server
guys you don't need to join my server if
you want myself if you want to I find my
server just check out my what what we
can't do recon awesomeness of the anime
upper discord server sorry bro
thank you guys no gotta soul maka and am
irika for being guests in today's stream
a lot of fun as always thanks everyone
in the chat for contributing including
the content cop talk stuff I like it all
the craziness the trolling it's fun I
enjoy it and yeah we'll be back again
next week as always and until then until
that time guys see ya yo kiyokawa
thank you